hello everyone and welcome to our
session enabling TELUS international to
securely work from anywhere with a topia
on the google cloud
i'm jim Rosicky from TELUS international
I'll be joined by Jonathan Lieberman for
my topia this session is really a case
study or a story of how the impact of Co
vid 19 created a challenge for TELUS
international that we were able to
quickly deploy a solution on the ectopia
platform to not only take our customers
today into the cloud but to also create
a go to market solution for the future
so as mentioned I'm Jim rocky I'm the
chief technology officer for TELUS
international and I'd like to introduce
Jonathan Lieberman for my topia it's
great to be with you here today Jim
presenting our success story with telus
International we're a Google cloud
technology partner premier partner that
helps enterprises turn every employee
into a remote worker within 24 hours and
at TELUS international we're a global
customer experience digital solutions
provider what that means as we design
build and deliver digital customer
solutions for the world's most respected
brands we've been doing it for more than
15 years and those brands include
companies such as Google to set the
stage a little bit for the challenge
that presented Occident particularly
around Co vat19 I want to share a little
bit about who we are and where we
operate because that plays into the
story so first tell us International we
have nearly 50,000 employees around the
globe we operate in over 20 countries we
have more than 600 clients and we
service those clients in more than 50
languages in particular we also have a
digital solutions arm these digital
solutions folks again they're actually
building and designing digital customer
experiences for our customers we have
just over 4,000 folks who actually do
this for us we operate those out of
seven countries and we have
more than 350 clients that are
particularly focused on digital
solutions so to set the stage March 17th
at that moment of those nearly 50,000
employees that we had TELUS
international had none actually of our
frontline team members who were actually
in a work from home environment we had
some back-office folks but really from a
frontline perspective we have zero team
members if you roll back the clock to
March 17 and think about where we were
in this overall pandemic it's amazing
how fast
times have changed here but on March
17th one of the first countries to
decide to put a stay at home order in
place was the Philippines and if you
look at that footprint that we had we
have a large presence at TELUS
international in the Philippines
fast-forward a little bit in each of the
days coming up actually in the next 11
days more than 6 countries that we
operated in started to put statehood
orders and stay home orders in place and
that trend continued so the challenge
that faced us was was apparent we needed
something to quickly deploy that allowed
us tell us international to take this
global work force that we had and get
them up and running in a work at home
environment and for that we reached out
to Google to look for a partner who can
help us get to that state thanks Jim
hi my name is John Torino and I'm the
Google cloud customer engineer working
with telus international for the past
three and a half years so tallis
international reached out to me in a
panic just as this whole global pandemic
thing was turning up and I'm not a VDI
expert by any stretch so I didn't know
what to recommend initially so I reached
out to people who are VDI experts within
our cloud team and I asked them for
their suggestions and they recommended
that I consider I Tokyo now I Tokyo as a
Google cloud partner of the year and
they had this fantastic reputation of
spinning up virtual desktop solutions
rapidly and securely I also reached out
to some like pure customer engineers who
had worked with a token before and they
had only great things to say about how
response
when collaborative they topia team was
with their customers so I felt a really
excited that we had an opportunity to
help TELUS international with this
urgent crisis and I went out and reached
out to the I toca team and that was a
sort of a great collaboration together
so over to you Jonathan thanks John
so I'm sitting at my desk and up pops
this email from TELUS international this
is the actual email from someone with a
great sense of humor asking rhetorically
if you could launch VDI over the weekend
that would be great and it turns out
they weren't kidding
tell us International literally needed
to provide thousands of workers access
to their mission critical business
applications and desktops over the
coming weekend now an email with this
kind of request might have struck fear
with other companies but for us it was
just another day at the office we were
not at all fazed by this request and our
teams were ready to get to work at the
most basic level I topia turns every
employee into a remote worker we do this
through a solution we call desktop as a
service which gives employees fast and
secure access to their desktops and apps
as though they were physically in the
office now here's Jamie who works in one
of TELUS international large deliver
centers in the Philippines who is now
working from home using any device a
Chromebook MacBook laptop PC or tablet
jamie is able to connect through a web
browser or a small app to a full cloud
hosted desktop or just the apps that she
uses most instead of the desktop or the
application being installed on a server
under her desk it's being hosted in the
nearest google cloud data center where
the connections are fast the security is
tight and the technology is unparalleled
so we built a topi to simplify and
modernize virtual desktop infrastructure
or VDI as most people commonly refer to
it today VDI is a technology that's been
around since the mid 90s it was invented
way before hyper scale cloud computing
companies enable their people to work
remotely unfortunately VDI got very
complex and and costly to install and
maintain it consists of multiple stacks
of hardware and software from compute to
storage to networking and this requires
a lot of up for an investment into a
bunch of gear and software that sits in
the data center and begins to depreciate
in value the minute that you buy it and
to make matters worse it cannot scale on
demand to handle a situation like we had
with kovat 19 and it must be managed by
a team of senior engineers so what we
did at AI topi was completely rethink
the approach to VDI by modernizing it is
a faster deploy simple to use cloud
native solution purpose-built for Google
cloud we got rid of the complex
technology stack and replaced it with a
unified console that can be easily
operated by a Tier one tech who can
enable and manage a worldwide VDI
deployment in any Google Data Center
with a single click thanks John so here
we were pandemic facing the world
through Google in the relationship we
were introduced away Autopia who showed
us and we're impressed with an
incredibly quick to deploy if you think
about the times we're talking about here
this sounds like something you would
have done over the course of weeks or
month with an introduction getting the
proof-of-concept we were up and running
on the proof of concept within the first
24 hours proving and testing the
technology to make sure it could work
soon after proving that it was available
to us now we needed to get into securing
it so we had to look at the architecture
we had to make sure that for our client
base for our employees not only could we
keep them safe but we can keep our
customers and their data safe we needed
to understand the architecture and how
that architecture is flexible enough for
us to secure the wide varieties of
customers that we have
so with that John I flipped it back over
to you to say hey how can we secure it
thanks Jim
so that the novel aspect about our
approach to VDI and the reason that
we're able to deploy it so quickly is
because our solution is pure automation
in
registration there's no software to
install no hardware to buy procure and
and implement we're automating what
Google already has in place and
everything runs in our customers
projects we consider five key elements
to what we automate in our modern Daz
deployment number one is the RDS
infrastructure platform itself in every
single region that's required in the
case of TELUS international seven
regions around the world number two is
the networking which consists of
firewalls VPNs and load balancers again
everything that Google brings to the
table from a technology point of view
the third is file servers which were
used for storage and data protection
fourth is that directory services that
leverage Google managed ad or allows a
customer to spin up their own domain
controllers it's a very flexible
approach and then finally a management
and monitoring console which leverages
stackdriver and Google bigquery thanks
John now we're checking off we're
checking the boxes for what we had so
March 17th we're stuck we needed
something quick to deploy we now have a
solution that we can deploy now we
needed to make it secure we need to make
sure that we can actually keep employees
safe and customers safe well as you saw
in the opening TELUS international we
have more than 600 clients there is no
one solution no one setting that's going
to apply to all 600 we needed this to be
customizable we needed it to be refine
Abul we needed to know that we can use
it for voice we need to know data heavy
applications some of our clients require
us to use their own VPN some of them
didn't want the desktop to be shown some
of them only wanted the certain tool
sets to be available some of them had
requirements for HIPAA some of them had
requirements you name it with 600
there's 600 different ways in which we
had this for that I reached back out to
John again to understand how we can
customize and refine the I Tokyo desktop
that's right Jim so in order to meet
Telus internationals requirements our
software enabled the security policies
rule
of permissions from Telus internationals
clients on Prem ABS to be extended into
Google Cloud in every situation as you
can imagine was different in our
solution acts as a bridge so that
there's no compromise and security
profile when one of Telus internationals
clients are being transitioned and
delivered through the cloud now every
client had needed to enable support for
a variety of use cases from Lite
workloads to productivity apps to
heavier graphical and media applications
and our start platform made it possible
with easy to add custom images to
provision workers auto scaling of
virtual machines intelligent user
routing to the nearest GCP data center
and this ensured a low latency and
delivered a very unified point-and-click
console in every browser and because our
software is orchestration only we don't
have any access to the customers data
this means that from a regulatory point
of view our software and the solution
that we delivered through Google was
able to adhere to the standards of that
Telus internationals clients demanded
from sock to PCI to FINRA Hipp FedRAMP
you name it John Jim back over to you
thanks John
so we're checking the boxes now on all
the things and again thinking back this
was literally days into this it seems
again like this would be the things we
do over the course of months so we were
quick to deploy we got that proof of
concept up and running able to show that
we can get the desktops deploy that they
were easy to maintain
we had to secure them we had to prove to
our clients and our employees that we're
able to make it a safe and productive
environment keeping their data as safe
as it would be as if it were in the
office then we need to customize it we
had to make it refine able every client
has their requirement that needed to be
in place so it needs to get it done and
we checked that off as well
lastly operating around the globe as we
do operating with as many folks as we do
we need
to make sure this solution was globally
scalable extremely important in a
virtual desktop environment low latency
the the distance between or the time
between where the servers are to where
the endpoints are people working from
home the smaller the better it just
works better that way so for that we
reach back out to Google to learn a
little bit about how we can deploy this
on the GCP so one of the biggest reasons
the Telus international team were
considering Google Cloud for the
solution is our global footprint with
over two dozen regions around the world
and new regions that are coming online
and regularly this is especially
important at TELUS international as
their employee base is spread out around
the world the sites in north of Central
America many countries in eastern
Western Europe India and the Philippines
so we design a deployment of AI topia
for TELUS international in six Google
cloud regions such that for every TELUS
international of geography they had at
least two GCP regions within the same
continent for additional redundancy and
the magic that brings together Telus
internationals employees to their
virtual desktop environments is one of
Google clouds greatest strengths a
private secure high speed global
backbone that's the same backbone that
already provides them access to Google
services that they rely on in their
daily lives and this ensures that all
Center Nationals employees working from
home around the world have a connection
through their home internet service
provider through the existing in-country
high speed peer connections that Google
has maintained for decades with telcos
around the world directly into Google's
backbone and then to their virtual
desktop and Google cloud and for each
site there are redundant network paths
to take to the servers especially for
employees in places like Guatemala and
the Philippines who rely on submarine
cables to connect to the internet having
a redundant network passed to a server
on the same continent instead of
undersea cables across the ocean means
that their latency is lower and their
user experience on their virtual desktop
is good and if TELUS international tried
to build their own private network and
peering to serve their work role
employees like this it would be
prohibitively expensive by Ryan Google
Cloud
a global deployment is easy so there's
no better scale than running this on the
Google cloud platform so now we've
checked all the boxes we had it up and
running
we made it serviceable and secure we've
refined it for our customer needs we've
leveraged the GCP to scale this around
the globe and literally within just a
few days we have stable operations so
where do we go from here well as I
mentioned also tell us international
with our Digital Solutions capabilities
we actually were able to take this to
the market so in a true sense of
partnership not only were we leveraging
this for our own needs but we also
decided that our success story is
something that a lot of other people are
going to need not only in the current
pandemic but as we look into the future
as well so one more time I reached back
out to John to say hey how can we take
advantage of this and a go to market
strategy thanks Jim so the natural next
question is is since we've gotten it
deployed and successfully on boarded
thousands of workers you know what can
we do next to make our partnership even
stronger and we talked to your solutions
folks who were so impressed with the
speed and simplicity of our platform
that we together decided to integrate it
and bring it to market as part of your
core customer care suite of solutions
yes you know it's become actually a part
of our overall package now what we call
work from anywhere so if you think about
what's required for someone to work from
home and this is the true future road of
operations that we're working toward
first you need to connect so as you look
at TELUS international x' work from
anywhere solution the first is a cloud
native omni-channel centered platform
that allows folks to connect with not
only their their own companies but also
with their customers anywhere that an
internet connection can reach right
smack in the middle of the platform is
exactly what we just talked about for my
Autopia to enable that remote virtual
desktop so that we can bring not only
the omni-channel solution but the full
suite of desktop applications that were
needed with inside your company or your
site bring those to the home in a secure
and safe manner and then lastly you need
to engage with people we talk about all
of the technology through this but it's
still at the end of the day people who
are working and connecting with their
customers so a full suite of products
for the customer experience that allow
us to say meaningfully engage with our
employees while they're working from
home so to give you a little sense of it
here's a snapshot of actually those
employees all working from their at home
environments with virtual desktops and
it wouldn't be complete if we didn't
show a little bit with all of us having
our pets there as well so a little bit
of that positive experience from the
work at home and some of the pets that
tell us international so with that I
thank you for joining us i'm jim Rosicky
you can reach out to me here at Jim
Rosicky at TELUS international comm and
I'll hand it to Jonathan Lieberman to
say a few words to close us out thanks
Jim so in our view this is only the
beginning of a very exciting partnership
to take our joint solution to the market
to help companies all over the world to
give their employees the ability to work
from home thanks again for joining us
and for having us and allowing us to
tell our success story